on va revenir sur cette image de la
semaine dernière qui a fait beaucoup
réagir les députés
LFI sont
affichésagné de sans abriis pour leur
apporter du soutien cette scène avait
été grandement critiquée sur les réseaux
notamment à cause de photos des mê du
put les filles autour d'une table dans
une brasserie très chique du 7e
arrondissement alors mathde Panau a dit
qu'elle n'avait pas mangé qu'il avait
pris un verre finalement il y a Hugo
Bernard LCIS qui a dit que même ce qu'il
avait mangé voilà il a même dit ce qu'il
avait mangé voilà il a dit ce qu'il
avait mangé
2 donc déjà il y a mensonge parce que
boire c'est non non mais elle a dit
qu'elle avait juste commence pas à
défendre tes amiselle a attends 2
minutes non mais elle a dit qu'il avait
juste pris un café maintenant elle dit
qu'elle a pris un hurger donc déjà ils
t'ont foutu dans la merde tu sais quoi
c'est parce que c'est toi qui [__]
dans la merde à chaque fois qu'ils font
des mensonges et voà ce qu'il a écrit
Hugo Bernard i je savais même pas qu'il
existait celui-ci euh voilà donc je sais
même pas qui c'est c'est qui d'ailleurs
député du Nord il avait été sanctionné
parce qu'il avait semé le le chaos dans
une commission des lois on en avait
parlé ici voilà il avait perdu la moié
de souvient de lui que pour ça écoute et
ben une fois de plus je vois que tes
amis font parler d'eux pour les bon pour
les bonnes raisons il a mis donc normal
les tocards puisque je n'avais ni
annoncé ni prévu de dormir sur place je
les ai salué sur place et je les ai
félicité pour leur action comme la
demande nous a été faite je confesse nav
par eu le courage d'autres collègues
dont notre
Présidente il a répondu donc à Jean-Marc
Morandini au blog de Jean-Marc morendini
hein et par contre chez Morandini blog
il s'enffiche clairement des sans abriis
et l'affiche cassement en essayant de
montrer ce genre de polémique niménable
j'ai mangé des lasagnes chèvres épinard
truc de dingue je ne suis pas sans abri
et je dors chez moi bon euh sa réponse
est comme accoutumé des des elle est je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez
géraldineelle est mépris en fait on s'en
fout du tube digestif desfistes en fait
oui c'est toi tu as mangé toi tu as bu
toi tu as pas dormi toas
m ils on utilisé ils ont utilisé la
cause des des des sansabris ils les ont
instrumentalisé en s'en foutant
complètement par ailleurs parce que à
aucun moment on parle des sansabris
depuis le début de cette polémique donc
je trouve que c'est juste indigne et
quand la politique fait ça en fait
finalement on tourne le dos à la
politique et après on s'étonne que les
gens vont pas n'ill pas voter Daniel
t'énervé toi aussi ah bah évidemment
parce qu'en fait ils se sont
complètement décrédibilisés on leur
demandait rien ils seraiit venus ils
auraient apporté par exemple des
couvertures voilà il serit mais pourquoi
allit dire
qu' on dit on été prre ver après ils ont
mangé après plus en
plus sur la photo on voit ce qu'ils ont
en train sont en train de manger ils
continuent à nous
dire il l'a dit luimême mais tu on vois
pas sur la photo ce faut dire les choses
comme elles sont ça sert à
rien sur la photo on voit pas autant pas
inventer de
btis pas on'en pas
donné
deséance meilleme
tours même
chose
on c'est nul fait mais c'est pas un
crime faut pas non
plus je peux lu répondre j'écoute comme
bêtementunation c'est
catastrophique et de l'autre côté le
droit au logement je je regrette malgré
tout comme tu dis la dérive idéologique
je regrette qu'aujourd'hui d n'envite
que la LFI pour venir parler parler de
ça parce que ça devrait concerner tous
les partis politiques de la même manière
que je sais pas l'écologie c'est pas
forcément un truc de gauche attende on
va laisser parler à gu et après vous
pourrez vous vous exprimer Vy non mais
tu as raison c'est pas c'est pasl en
blaser la gauche n'a pas le le monopole
on y va vas-y ma chérie tu peux faire
une phrase c'est chaud he euh la gauche
n'a pas le monopole du cœur tu as raison
tout le monde devrait être ému de ça en
l'occurrence c'est eux qui tentent
quelque chose qui je suis d'accord est
particulièrement malaisant et et mal
fait mais je pense que l'intention n'est
pas ne mérite pas autant euh voilà je
trouve que autour de la table on est
quand même vachement virulent pour un
truc qui est pas non plus Dingo quoi
c'est pas
maaisûelleelle a des dans une T et elle
sort du restaurant elle sort du
restaurant doucheendant 3 semaines-
queouime pas cette hypocrisie et en plus
ce soirl je suis journaliste politique
mon travail c'estîn ave des politiques
ils étaient dans le restaurant juste à
côté du mien ce soirl et il y avait
presque tout le group restant je
mangeais pas leur table j'étais dans le
restaurant d' côté
bâtard dans restaurant il y avait leur
attassé de presse leur groupe tout le
monde n'est pas député sur cette photo
les mecs ils vont au restaurant ensuite
ils font leur apping avec leur Airpod
ils arrivent ils mettent de la dalle en
dessous de la tente et il pensent avoir
fait un truc de bien aujourd'hui combien
y a-t-il d' SDF qui ne sont plus dans la
rue grâce à Mathilde Panau aucun zé zé
ils ont menti aussi sur un autre
point on nous avait expliqué que tout
tous les partis politiques étaient
invités à venir participer en fait c'est
totalement faux c'est bernalicis
lui-même 15 jours avant est allé au D
comment on pouvait monter une opération
ça a été raconté par un journal de
gauche donc c'est sans risque c'est une
histoire
réelleque d qui a été demandé à la LFI
c'est eux qui qui ont sollicité le droit
au logement et le droit au logement leur
a dit venez quand vous voulez et ils
sont V excuse-moi toi qui dis qu'on est
des méchants et qu'on récupère tout ça
imagine si Jordan
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bar
Jordan
bar im Jordan bar avit ça
acanchement on serait tous vraiment mis
V
debout justement j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour toi il y a quelquun qui t'e Didier
[Rires]
pzord avait été sous la tente 2 he et
serait reparti en disant je vais passer
la est-ce que Libération n' aurait pas
fait qure pages un dossier spécial et
ça on pas que des méchants
quientquoi tu dis je pense pas qu'il
aurait fait ça enfin qu' qu'il fasse ça
pourquoi tout d'un coup la gauche la
gauche a juste le cœur la droite n'
pasur non mais c'est souvent je suis
désolé de forcé de constater que c'est
souvent des sujets qui sont pris en main
par la gauche plus que par la droite et
encore plus par l'extrême droite
l'extrême droite l'extrême droite sa
priorité c'est de parler d'immigration
dans
quand même un autre truc il est tombé
dans le
panneau
bravo s'il vous plaît ché ça fait 5
minutes qu'on parle de ce sujet on a
même pas eu Gill verd g ça change sache
que on t' moi je ne dirai rien mais moi
je vais vous répondre directement à vous
les yeux dans les yeux tu me parles pas
V ah si parce que votre cher pardon non
mais il
cherche parle-nous à nous attends
résution laissez-le laissez-le faire
laissez-le prendre ses
responsabilités redonnez-moi ma fiche
elle est où la fiche alors elle est où
alors nor les tocar normal les tocar je
ne suis pas sans abri je dors chez moi
normal les tocar êtes-vous choqué par la
réponse du député insoumis Hugo Bern sm
Miss là
ou men fousp c'est le mot de ton ami je
m'en fous total non mais je te le dis
donc et déjà pas ton petit ton tu
t'avance pas comme ça d'accord tu te
mets derrière Dani tu te mets bien
devant que je te vois parce que toi je
t'aime hein et tu te mets derrière
Daniel pour que je puisse bien profiter
du physique de Daniel lors de ce moment
difficile merci vas-y tu sais ça c'est
des moments que je redoute quand
j'arrive le lundi je me dis quand est-ce
que Gilles Bernez va prendre la parole
hein sur ses amis ou sur des sujets sur
lesquels on n'est pas du tout d'accord
avec lui donc Daniel approche-toi chérie
que je te vois bien par que quand je te
vois tu me détends toi tu es ma talassut
et lui c'est mon cauchemar c'est mon
anidalgo allez non pour moi vous êtes la
vertu incarné là je suis triste parce
que vous posez la question a-t-il menti
ou pas et vous connaissez la réponse il
n'a pas menti il n'a pas
menti lu pris ver la question qu'on pose
là êtesvous choqué par la réponse du
député
normalputé par
comme
normal normal les toar c'est normal
pas le mépris quand il dit moi je suis
pas avant que tu répondes j'aimerais
qu'on voit le résultat du sondage pour
une fois de plus te montrer tu es un et
un non mais tu es fou
quoi% quand même à chaque fois tu es
dans les bas fonds tu dégoûtes tout le
monde allez il n'a pas menti du tout il
a dit dès lebce qu'on t'a demandé il n'a
pas menti on t
dit question je suis pas choqué demandé
à F est-ce que tu veux te marier avec
moi elle a répondu à ta question elle
t'a dit je ne sais pas vas-y elle a dit
oui je veux bien non mais RA ça fait 5
ans je veux bien cy il arrête de
m'appeler cy
app- monsieur tu veux que je te dise ma
depuis depuis le début il dit la vérit
j'aimerais te demander un truc aussi que
je demande au téléspectateurs je vais il
est 19h33 à partir du moment quand tu me
parlesi j'aimerais que tu regardes
là-bas mais non
AR c'est dur à faire non le Pau c'est
trop dur c'est trop dur à faire je vais
regarder Kelly parce que ça me donne de
l'énergie c'est vrai qu'on se ressemble
beaucoup il y a énormément de similitude
je je ne suis pas choqué parce que lui
il dit la vérité depuis le début il y a
pas d'hypocrisie ils sont allés là-bas
ils ont dit qu'ils voulaient parle pas
queon parle sans abri oui c'est de la
communication mais ce sont les seuls à
le faire mais toitoi nouau ferme ta
[Applaudissements]
gueule
tu par tu
amis
il as tout DEES amis tu as
tout mal dans la vi técas comment
ça ex même comport sur les plateau de
télé sur les partout il font les malins
il gros bras et dès qu'il se retrouve
dans la rue et bouffons c'est les seuls
qui lèvent le voile sur le drame des
3300 qui sont
all quo ils ont fait quoi arrête ta
démagogie par on
pr j'aimais qu'il te répond radan parce
que comme tu lui as dit ta
gueule sur le sujet çaavais été un
député dans marche qui avait fait un
twet en marquant les tocar ou ou qui
avait fait preuve de ce mépris de classe
du mépris de classe dont fait preuve
Hugo bernalis tu aurais certainement été
le premier à toser pu a gueulé ici non
norm pas mes
amiselle frér c'est pas mes amis je
connais pas et je l'aime pas beaucoup
mais c'est pas grave non il a il a
depuis le début depuis le début il a
toujours dit moi j'y vais mais je ne
dors pas là-bas c'est quoi ton histoire
là excuse-moi est-ce que je t'ai je ne
suis pas choqué parce qu'il est honnête
non non normal les to tu es pas choqué
non je suis pas choqué député non je
suis pas choqué je suis pas choqué s'il
te plaît défonce il
est défend notre présidente Mathilde
pano qui elle avant a menti face caméra
en disant qu'elle avait suivi toute la
conférence de presse de Macron avec les
sans-abriis alors que ça c'est sûr
qu'elle était à l'intérieur de la
brasserie elle a menti face caméra il la
défend donc excuse-moi en plus de dire
normal letocar qui est indigne d'un
députés voilà il a tout faux sur toute
la ligne et si tes amis sont si
forts puisque tes amis sont les seuls de
la gauche à défendre les gens très
pauvre pourquoi la gauche est si basse
dans les classes populaires et pourquoi
le RN qui ne fait rien est si haut essay
de réfléchir ça tu nous fais un truc et
tu reviens qu'est-il va nous faire il va
rien faire il va ranger des affaires de
Fatou enc va faire quel chose par qu'il
a déjà fait quelque
chose réféchir unu on n pas on n' pas
entendu Valérie Benin là-dessus qui est
tell délicieuse ah Mo je vous remercie
non je trouve je ne comprends pas toi
qui est toujours extrêmement choqué et
qui veut qu'il y ait une
représentativité de de nos élus et que
et et ça ne te plaît pas quand ils
parlent mal là en l'occurrence il y a un
mépris de classe absolu et quand on
termine par un PS je ne suis pas sans
abri et je dors chez moi dont on dont on
entend moi moi je ne suis pas sans abri
et moi je dors chez moi il a un vrai
mépris pardonne-moi excuse-moi mais
c'est pas comme ça qu'un député qui
justement défend les 330000 sans abris
devrait s'exprimer et répondre à
l'ensemble des Français pardon r moi
j'avais déjà donné mon avis je trouve
que de faire ça ça se fait pas d'aller
juste une nuit à tour de rôle chacun
comme si cétait Disney et sa réponse bah
je trouve que ils veulent pas qu'on les
insulte ils en font un plat quand ils se
font insultés partout à droite à gauche
ils font des vidéos pour pleurer parce
qu'on les a insultter dans le train et
cetera et cetera moi je trouve non les
d'appeler on parle pas comme ça
quand es député de la même manière que
je suis pas content quand on insulte un
député je suis pas content quand eux il
parlent comme ça parce qu'ils ont parce
que ça se fait pas de parler comme ça le
message il est mauvais après va dire aux
gens de se tenir tranquille et de pas
être grossier si toi en tant que député
de la République payé par la République
tu te comportes comme un charlot après
pas pleurer ce qui arrive derrière c'est
normal et les SF c'est pas un jeu
arrêtez d'aller à tour de rôle dormir
avec eu nuit et parlez pas de courage il
y a rien de courageux d'aller dormir
avec
G c'est pas à Paris c'est dans toute la
France et c'est pas parce que tu vas
réquisitionner un immeubleosmanien que
tu vas
som parce que tu fais rêver les gens des
TR qui n'arriveront jamais donc c'est
que des utopistes et des rêveurs qui
sont cru par voilà par les amis Gill
verd sont ses amis donc il après moi je
vais dire non mais arrête c'est bon non
mais moi je voudrais revenir sur sur
l'invitation précisément parce que tu
dis g qu'ils sont pas hypocrites donc
reviens précisément sur ce qu'a dit
Valérie en gros comment ça s'est passé
cette opération tu dis que c'est de la
com très bien pourquoi pas de la com en
politique après et tout tous les parties
en fond là concrètement comment ça s'est
passé qui a invité qui et pourquoi on
est d'accord donc c'est les insoumis qui
ont demander à être invité attends
attends Gérald on va se retrouver dans
un instant on va vous répondre le le
génie des Carpates euh dans un instant
et puis il y aura le débat du jour on va
enchaîner et ouais on va écouter si vous
voulez que je vous dis c'est comme ça à
tout de suite